aquí tenemos una función periódica y lo
que quiero que hagamos es pensar en cuál
es la línea media de esta gráfica la
línea media va a ser la línea horizontal
en la cual la mitad de la función se
encuentra por encima de esta línea y la
otra mitad se va a encontrar por debajo
de ella ahora quiero también que
pensemos en la amplitud que tanto se
aleja la función de la línea media tanto
arriba como abajo que debe ser la misma
distancia ya que la línea media está
justo a la mitad de la función y
finalmente el periodo de una función que
tanto se debe avanzar o variar en x para
llegar al mismo punto del ciclo de esta
función periódica los invito a que pausa
en el vídeo y piensen en estos tres
conceptos
analicemos primero la línea media una
forma de pensar en ello es ver qué tan
alta es la función vemos que esta
función tiene su valor máximo aquí
cuando es igual a 4 en esta parte
y tiene su valor menor acá cuando ya es
igual a menos 2 para encontrar la línea
media podemos hacer varias cosas podemos
calcular así a ojo ver cuál es la parte
que está a la mitad de este intervalo
podemos contar los elementos que hay y
encontrar el que está a la mitad o
podemos sacar el promedio de estos
valores
4 - 2 o 4 más menos 2 va a ser igual a 2
si lo dividimos entre 2 nos va a dar 1
así que nuestra línea media se encuentra
cuando es igual a 1
aquí está entonces para encontrar la
línea media lo que hicimos fue y es
igual a el promedio del valor máximo y
el valor mínimo que es 4 el máximo más
el mínimo menos 2
entre dos para obtener el promedio que
es igual a 2 entre 2 igual a 1 y por eso
nuestra línea media se encuentra aquí
así que esta es mi línea media
ahora veamos la amplitud que tanto varía
esta función con respecto a la línea
media tanto por arriba como por debajo
de esta que será la misma cantidad ya
que esta línea media se encuentra justo
a la mitad de esta función otra forma de
verlo es de aquí de la línea media que
tan lejos se encuentra el punto máximo
este de acá pues está a 123 unidades de
distancia lo mismo habrá de la línea
media hacia el valor menor de la función
contamos a partir de esta línea 123
unidades otra forma de encontrar este
valor es tomar el valor máximo que en
este caso es 4 y restarlo al valor donde
se encuentra la línea media 4 menos una
es igual a 3 así que la amplitud es
igual a 3
por último veamos el periodo cuando
pienso en el periodo trato de encontrar
un punto conveniente en la curva por
ejemplo vamos a tomar este punto de acá
esto es conveniente porque cuando x
igual a menos 2 y es igual a 1 y lo que
hago es seguir la curva hasta llegar al
mismo valor de iu pero aquí hay algo
importante a tomar en cuenta llegamos a
este punto de la curva donde tenemos que
es el mismo valor de g pero no es un
ciclo aquí todavía no llegamos a
completar un sitio de esta función
porque cuando iniciamos nuestro
recorrido en esta curva nuestra
pendiente iba hacia arriba se incrementa
conforme x se va incrementando sin
embargo en este punto no esté pendiente
va hacia abajo y ese decremento conforme
x va aumentando entonces todavía no
llegamos a nuestro ciclo así que
seguimos recorriendo nuestra curva hasta
que llegamos a este punto de nuevo que
vale 1 pero la pendiente de mi función
se está incrementando igual que como
inicia aquí aquí ya tengo un ciclo
completo entonces tengo que ver cuánto
me desplacé en x durante este ciclo para
encontrar el periodo comencé aquí con x
igual a menos 2
a x igual a 0 así que me desplacé en x 2
unidades mi periodo es igual a 2 y para
que quede más claro esto vamos a hacerlo
de nuevo voy a ponerlo con otro color
ahora vamos a partir de este punto
cuando x es igual a 0 y es igual a 1 y
encontramos que al seguir la curva no
está pendiente va a aumentar
seguimos siguiendo la curva hasta que
encontramos un valor de ye otra vez
igual a 1 pero este no es nuestro ciclo
porque la pendiente es diferente de como
iniciamos aquí la pendiente es negativa
va hacia abajo así que debemos seguir
nuestra curva seguimos las seguimos las
seguimos hasta llegar nuevamente a este
valor de jane donde se cumple que
nuestra pendiente es la misma de como
iniciamos nuestro ciclo y aquí veo
cuánto me desplacé mx para llegar acá de
x igual a cero hasta x igual a 2
por lo tanto confirmó que mi periodo es
2 mi periodo es igual
a 2 unidades